i love this man i've known him for ever
and a day he was at my wedding
and uh and he's the the best at what he
does and it was great to hear his voice
clemson notre dame on saturday night on
nbc sports and then i watched him
get us ready for that boat race my gosh
in tampa last night he's mike tarico how
are you mike
hey buddy how are you rich i am fine
you're all traveled out in a world where
hardly anybody's traveling
yeah it was it was quite a weekend you
couldn't ask for a
for a better weekend in terms of uh
games and events and all that stuff
it was uh it was quite a weekend well so
i will give you the floor first on the
scene uh in notre dame
uh it just you know popped through the
television set um and we saw all those
kids running on the field but
the football first aspect of it um what
what did we learn
from that game on saturday night mike uh
so so
let's go let's go big picture with
clemson first clemson's a really
excellent team i know we've known that
but you know sometimes
you can say it's a team a team is one
year and i should rephrase it as a
elite program because they were without
three of their better defensive players
their the quarterback of their defense
james skowski a linebacker inside
an nfl caliber defensive lineman and
another linebacker actually the son of
mike jones who made the tackle
of kevin dyson in the rams titan super
bowl
in atlanta uh he's a very good
linebacker for them so they were without
three significant parts of their team
on defense and then they're without as
good a player as theirs on the offensive
side and trevor lawrence
and they still on the road against a
really good team went to overtime so
i think it just tells us what a great
program dabo sweeney's built
there having said that dj uyounga la the
quarterback played really well
he's gonna be a future star they've got
great things to build around after
lawrence
but on the notre dame side it shows you
that even though they're in a league for
a year they're still an independent
as an independent in this construct
notre dame can still be
extremely relevant at the highest level
of college football and that's full
credit to brian kelly
who after a four and eight season hit
the reset button
i won't go through all the things that
they did internally but
they have a product that's turning out
nfl caliber players
and can beat a great program like
clemson so full credit to where notre
dame is now and certainly
as it has been for a lot of our lives in
the conversation for
best teams in the country well i mean
they all they got to do i guess is
win out um and yeah and maybe you
see a rematch here and and i i i would
sign up for a rematch of this in
in a semi-final game if that's the way
the the committee can
can line it up and i i would take
clemson notre dame alabama the ohio
state if that's the way it all works out
uh at the end of the day yeah right now
mike uh
except for the folks who are listening
and watching in cincinnati and out in
provo
i i think yeah most would be in
agreement on that you know
the bearcats the cougars have had very
good seasons and
do they deserve to be part of the
conversation here's the curious thing
and this is why
i really get frustrated with the sport i
love i know you know
our the friends that our old employer
espn they make such
hay in the conversation of sports and
the the
chaos that comes with college football
really gives you a lot of juice for
all the shows between games week to week
right but but it's just so
stupid that what happens on the field is
still then has to be sifted through
um a selection committee and all this
other stuff
the playoffs should be eight teams there
are five leagues that play
in this level those five leagues the
power five their champions however they
choose to crown them
should be in the playoffs one team from
the group of six should be in the
playoffs and then the other two best
teams
and let's play it on the field this year
and every year it's really
pretty simple to figure out and a way to
do things enrich with
the finances at colleges and
universities and athletic departments
losing eight figures
in their athletic budgets these this
year i think it might hasten
the conversation for expanding a playoff
to eight teams
and get more playoff generated money as
a part of this especially with
the other sports that people are trying
to hang on to clemson just cut its track
and field program
no program's making more money over the
stretch than clemson is right
and they just had to cut a program uh
that that's turned out some good
athletes so
it's a it's a time i think that college
football should really look at it
because let me just give you this point
if notre dame plays clemson
in an acc championship game trevor
lawrence plays everybody else plays it's
in charlotte
clemson wins there might be a good
argument to keep notre dame out of a
playoff
cincinnati or byu is unbeaten and that
would that would be part part of the mix
even though they've split it would just
be the timing of it it's just it's kind
of odd to watch
the system work that way but it's a big
possibility well
and plus you know what if notre dame
would do that and win again does that
mean clemson
you know then get look we could go back
and forth on this but
but yeah exactly i i'm i'm i'm totally
in lockstep with you i've been pounding
this table that i'm sitting behind right
now for years about an 18 play-off and i
think now's the time to do it we just
saw
like literally this year and i know that
that that this is already that horse is
back in the barn right now but
i'll still say it here anyway since
we're we're opining
um that that this is the year you saw
major league baseball expanded their
playoffs because of what happened with
with a
an obviously different season due to
covet
uh the nfl right now has already got a
plan in the in the front right drawer
uh desk drawer of uh probably the
commissioner and everyone else's
uh in case that they have to just have
an expanded season because
the postseason because the regular
season is changed by this virus
why not right now i mean like this would
be it right now for everybody to enjoy
every you're right buddy every sport has
the balls up in the air
because of the complete tumult that
there has been with the regularity of
the sports calendar
so it's a great opportunity to step back
reassess come back in a different way
uh randy moss are not randy moss of the
vikings fame
and the future hall of famer i should
say but randy moss who works on our
horse racing coverage and works on nfl
network at times as well
yes he has said for years about horse
racing the triple crown should space
itself out so the derby goes in may and
then the preakness around memorial day
at the belmont around 4th of july
weekend it would make more sense
well it's a time to do that because all
the balls are up in the air do what's
best for the long-term
interest from 2020 to 2040
in your sports if the nba goes to 72
regular season games
however folks have to re-divvy this up
what an
opportunity to do it maybe hockey saw
something that
we can take the those seeds five through
twelve in each conference
and play these many best of five playoff
series to get the final
16 teams eight per conference like they
did in the restart in the bubbles
maybe there was something out of this
year that will create new different
and higher valued inventory because
there's a ton of sports inventory out
there
so if yours isn't high quality and of
interest
it's time to move on or you'll get
passed and i think that given all the
tunnel
it'll be a great time to do it college
football needs to be at the front of
that train
decided on the field make each
conference matter
don't give me a debate about the pac-12s
relevance to
the sec play in your league win your
conference play in the postseason
then you crown a true national champ
mike here we go here on the rich eisen
show
i was going to bring this up last but
i'll bring it up now since we're talking
about reconfigured sports schedules due
to the virus it's masters week here we
are in
november and i'm seeing the photographs
that uh that the masters is
is posting on on social media of the
leaves
changing at augusta national like
something we've
never seen before what do you think
we're gonna see this week mike
what do you think yeah well i'm like i'm
bummed because i'm not going to
personally be there for my first time
in quite some time uh for the coverage
but i was down there a couple of weeks
ago
and i can tell you that it's not full
fall foliage
but it's just beautiful in its own way
you're gonna miss the
the hues of the azaleas and everything
else but it's just not
it it's not the same in that way but the
place still looks spectacular it will
play
slightly differently because of the type
of grass and the time of season
but it will still play fast it's still
perfect
the green speeds are going to be there
like they are in april
and i'm just going to put this on your
radar on monday
this week you will be talking about
bryson de chambeau and augusta
all across sports he's gonna hit the
ball
to places that we've never seen anybody
hit it off to see at augusta national
right
he's gonna have a myriad of shots in for
second shots
at this golf course that will be
different than
uh almost anyone we've seen even when
they had to quote tiger proof augusta
national
uh duchamp is gonna have you know
nothing he's not gonna hit any
four or five irons into greens uh he in
all likelihood is gonna be
kind of seven eight iron in and i'm
talking about par fives not just the par
fours
uh i i hope he drives it well because it
will be
one of those things where you can't wait
to see where he's gonna hit it next it
could be
very fascinating doesn't mean he's going
to win he's still got a putt
and i know he did in the last major and
he's confident about his putting there
i'm sure but
i'm just telling you rich it is going to
be the talk of
golf and thus because it's the masters
the talk of the sports world this week
where deshambo hits it and what he's
going to be able to do from those spots
so then let's come up with the phrase
right now let's front load it what
because you can't say bryson proof it
will they like brysonize it are they
going to brysonize
are they going to brysonize augustus
something like that i mean
the shambis do you like do you like that
i do i don't know to sham buys it
because
they have run out of real estate right
have they run out of real estate there
to move things back there are places
there are places that they
can extend some holes 13 comes to mind
it's been a conversation for the last
couple of years
but rich it's less uh bryson doing it
or augusta national i should say this is
a case for all golf courses
as we go forward bryson is hitting it
farther than we've ever seen anybody hit
it
but he's also hitting it straight and
that's the remarkable thing when you go
back to wing foot
yes he did hit it deep but he also hit
it in play so you know you can say grow
rough which at augusta nashville there's
a second cup but it's not the same
effect as the rough at
us opens or other tree-lined courses
and yet he still has the opportunity
because he's way down there to get it on
the green
here with a lack of high rough you're
going to have even more opportunities
so there's not much you can do it's just
going to be interesting to watch
to other players try to catch up to the
speed carrying the ball 360 in the air
that he has the the speed the power all
that stuff
he's i think rich he is as fascinating
an athlete as we have in professional
sports right now
and when you look at the physics
background how he's approached this the
protein the food
all the things he's doing it's really
intriguing i just think that
if he has another big week after winning
the us open even though they're not on
the same time the calendar
it's really going to send that sport in
into a very interesting stretch
of people trying to catch his distance
so then uh last one for you on this
is there a par four that you think he
could table from the t
do you think is is there one no yeah
yeah three
three the the third hole after the part
five second
you come back parallel to that and the
third plays under 400 yards he could
could get it there um it's a narrow it's
a narrow green
it's a difficult miss if you missed to
the right uh if you're in the left lefty
you might have an angle the other thing
is there are no
patrons no fans right so some of those
areas are a little more accessible than
they might have been
otherwise when patrons are lining those
spots that we've always seen them
uh that's why i'm really intrigued to
watch hear the reports back from the
practice rounds and then watch him
uh this week it's gonna be i think it's
gonna be really cool to see and i think
it's gonna be
the the chitchat of the sports world
after he plays on thursday and friday a
few more minutes left with mike tarico
again fresh back from uh south bend
calling the
notre dame overtime win over clemson on
nbc and then
uh hosting uh football night in america
uh as
always uh on sunday nights on nbc what
do you take out of last night mike what
do you take from that
well i i was heartened that uh all the
gang on sam ponder show on
sunday nfl countdown and then you
and my man kurt mooch and michael
you all you all picked they were happy
too not
in the house that's correct so so we we
we had we had good we could lead
blockers in a football night in america
when
all of us picked buccaneers as well
uh it just allowed for the triple troll
to take place in the same space
uh so good on you new orleans uh
should have known at that point that i
should have gone the other way when
everybody else
was going i i was stunned not stunned in
new orleans one but stunned with
seeing that tampa team that we thought
okay here they go now i mean
you know they've got like this little
fantasy football team of guys here with
edwin's and god and evans godwin and
obviously abs added gronk and fournette
and
they they got one of a kind they got
everything here
and the defense just was
completely out of place and off pace
what a brilliant game plan by sean
payton
and let's credit drew brees because yeah
drew brees doesn't throw 40 yards 45
yards in the air
much if at all this year but man the
timing the accuracy it really
is like um watching a a beautiful
broadway play
uh a musical too with the rhythm the
timing the pace the lines
the spots they hit and we should have
thought about what they did
against a good chicago team in the last
two weeks without their top two
receivers
and now you get 149 catch guy and a
super bowl caliber receiver and emanuel
sanders
on the other side of michael thomas
throw them back in and everybody else
hit a good rhythm and they look fabulous
full credit to them
good for them and you know it's nice
that nfc race is now
wide open and they've got a huge
advantage with
a game with a really two game lead
because of the head-to-head sweep
in the nfc south and that's the
difference between a one seed
and a five seed and that's a lot as we
saw last year
with seattle and san francisco all right
let's go sports talk format and ask the
poll question of uh mike tarico fellow
syracuse orange
chris brockman ask it of mike tarico
please all right mike who's the best
team in the nfl
steelers chiefs bills or saints those
are the top four wreck
by record that's why we went yeah yeah
yeah i
would i would take uh i bet a slice at
the varsity which is our pizza jointed
accused is well done chris wells no well
well knows uh i would take a varsity
slice
on the chiefs at this point
um you know pittsburgh i think is is
very very good
i just have a lot of belief in that
kansas city offense no matter what your
answer is defensively i feel like
they've got
one last move on often it feels like the
chiefs are always batting in the bottom
of the inning
that no matter what you do in the top of
the inning they've got like one more to
play
and they can get you last great and i
think on the offensive side they did
that and
defensively i i get the feeling
mcdermott's crew is going to start
coming together i know they gave up 30
plus last week
but i i trust them when they get in the
playoff spot so i think just because the
offense is a
touch more explosive than pittsburgh
i'll go there right now well and i was
talking to
uh our our uh colleague peter king in
the first
hour mike about the the one aspect or
metric
that is the perfect uh that perfectly
encapsulizes
just how mahomes is looked at
at such a ripe age of 25 it it's not
you know although you can talk about the
half billion dollar contract or the mvp
in the super bowl or anything else it is
that we are already in the media
treating him
like belichick for coach of the year or
phil jackson for coach of the year like
why give it to him you know he's already
got everything uh let's spread it around
let's spread it around like we're not
looking
at him as the clear mvp that he is
playing as
and he's 25. that's right mike right
what what year was michael jordan not
the most valuable player in the nba i
know ron right now right that great
kind of conference exactly yes rick
i i kind of i was when the conversation
of the moment was that four weeks ago
hey russell wilson never got an mvp but
he's having an mvp season
like it's it's september can we wait and
so i'm trying not to
inject myself in mvp conversation until
we get to
right around thanksgiving time because
you know a guy can play 10 games 11
games he gets hurt it changes the
calculus
trevor lawrence misses two games it's
going to change the conversation about
the heisman race a little
long as he comes back and plays well
it's still going to be there but it does
impact it so you can't get too far ahead
on these things
but last night when we stopped into 25
touchdowns
one interception think about that for a
minute 25
and 1. that's extraordinary stuff
he always gets it to the end zone and he
never gives it to you
that's as valuable with the most
important position in all sports for an
eight and one team too
on unbelievable oh my gosh my great
weekend
loved hearing you watching you seeing
you um you know as always thanks for the
call you take care you be well
any any time pal best of susan the kids
you bet same to you that's uh mike
tarico here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here